parts of France came to a standstill as
workers staged their biggest Nationwide
strike of the year so far a year that is
far from over yesterday more than a
million people took part in
demonstrations against a proposed
government plan to raise the retirement
age from 62 to 64. the protests were
largely peaceful but there were clashes
with Riot police in some cities Elaine
Cobb is in Paris for us Elaine good
morning
good morning the controversy raging
around mackerel's pension reforms
continues in the Senate behind me and on
the streets where French workers were
out in force yesterday
[Music]
more than a million people marched in
towns and cities across France to say no
to president macron's reforms that we'll
see them working longer and retiring
later
this public servant says she has been
working since she was 17 and was first
due to retire at 60 then 62. now it will
be 64. she says it's not fair to change
the age of mid-career
the protests Drew workers from all walks
of life a reminder how the changes will
affect everyone who isn't already
retired or about to retire this year
the atmosphere at the Paris March ranged
from light-hearted
too aggressive there were some violent
clashes in Paris on the sidelines of the
marches with what police called radical
elements that had nothing to do with the
protest the unions say they're pleased
with the turnout at the marches across
the country and with the numbers who
went on strike in sectors from transport
to education to energy
yesterday's Nationwide strikes hit
Railroad and Air transport hard causing
widespread delays and cancellations it
led to blockades of ports and oil
refineries and closed power plants
a concern to people already hit by an
ongoing energy crisis the unions say
there are other ways to ensure there
will be money to pay for today's young
people when they retire
but many like this woman say president
macron's government doesn't listen they
talk down to us she complained
French women say they will lose more
than most and protest it again here
today at the Senate the debate continues
inside as outside the Union's promise to
keep protesting until the reforms are
withdrawn Gail
Elaine Cobb reporting from Paris we
thank you